Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new spider-man 3 video and i'll explain
what's happening with the future of spider-man
in the mcu after this the future of spider-man
movies in general there's going to be some big
changes and there's an important reason why
they're rolling so hard on spider-verse during
spider-man 3. i know everyone's hoping for a
new spider-man 3 teaser trailer of some sort
really soon they're about due for some news
but if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos of course
i'll do videos for anything that they release
obviously they're going to be filming spider-man
3 for a while but they do have enough footage
to actually release a trailer if they wanted to
as you've seen the past few months more and
more characters from the tobey maguire and
andrew garfield spider-man movies have been
added to spider-man 3 and like clockwork
andrew garfield emma stone even kirsten dunst
cameos were announced recently most of the reports
are saying that tobey maguire is still getting
ready to sign his contract but just hasn't quite
done that yet but he was seen at a costume fitting
so it does seem like he's eventually going to be
a lock for a cameo in the movie one of my new
favorite jokes though is that there's so many
cameos that it seems like are happening in this
movie the one that people are most hyped up about
is tom holland hopefully getting a cameo in his
own movie but even before all this spider-burst
stuff there were all these sinister six things
that the sony people were talking about so we
knew that they were eventually going to build up
to a spider-man vs the sinister six movie so why
then are they pivoting to all this spider-verse
stuff too why do you need to add that into the
mix if you're already doing something as big
as spider-man vs the sinister six in the mcu
they totally don't need to roll that hard
there are a couple important reasons why
they're doing this setting up the next 10 years
of spider-man for practical plot reasons but also
there are a lot of financial reasons why they
would roll so hard on spider-verse so quickly
amy pascal said a couple years ago after the
animated spider-verse movie was released it was
so well received one of the best spider-man movies
of all time that the studio had also been thinking
about doing live-action spider-man into the
spider-verse but at the time the producers
of the animated spider-verse movie said that sony
had blocked their attempts to do cameo scenes with
tom holland andrew garfield and tobey maguire
saying that it was too soon to put them all in
the movie but this is a couple years ago at one
point i was supposed to be in it yeah there was
going to be another peter parker like it was like
a scene in a train station or something and like
it was it was going to be like a like an easter
egg i was going to walk through the background and
say like hey kid or something and never happened
i'm heartbroken that was just tom holland talking
about this deleted scene in the subway that you
saw during the spider-verse trailers that didn't
make it into the actual movie that's where his
cameo scene would have happened but then a couple
years go by and kevin feige at comic-con 2019
which feels like it was almost a million years
ago at this point remember when we used to go
to conventions he talked about how the concept
of the multiverse would be a big trope of marvel
phase 4 starting with the Wandavision episodes her
alternate tv looking reality where she brings
vision to life and magics up her two mutant
children from the comics wiccan and speed or billy
and tommy then they announced doctor strange 2
into the multiverse of madness is going to be peak
multiverse craziness in the mcu and then announced
that sam raimi himself mr spider-man from back in
the day is going to direct the movie people start
wondering if he's going to include tobey maguire
cameos during that but then the rumors about
spider-verse easter eggs and spider-man 3 start so
it all starts to make sense things come into shape
way more multiverse than you ever expected in
spider-man but it makes sense given how the
multiverse is going to affect the story of all
the marvel phase 4 movies in disney plus series
in some ways some more than others and because
there's a mystery crossover movie on the sony
marvel sharing contract for spider-man there's two
movies there's spider-man 3 in a mystery crossover
movie now it seems like that unannounced mystery
crossover movie is going to be doctor strange too
so spider-man will go from spider-man 3 and now
because of the way they've rearranged the marvel
schedule doctor strange 2 comes out right after
that he'll just cameo in that just like thor
crossed over into the first doctor strange movie
then dr strange showed up during thor ragnarok
and while this is all happening in the background
you have john watts the director of the spider-man
movies in the marvel universe slowly transitioning
away and pivoting to the fantastic four franchise
so where does that leave spider-man solo
movies going forward after spider-man 3.
marvel still wants to have spider-man in the
mcu for the rest of time if possible i mean
i'd probably buy sony outright if they could but
it'd probably be a big anti-trust situation we
know that sony confirmed that they do have a 4th
movie planned with tom holland a 4th spider-man
solo movie they didn't say what that movie is
going to be but after that is a big question
mark it seems like it might actually be the last
legit tom holland spider-man solo movie in the mcu
but not the end of spider-man in the mcu and
not the end of spider-man movies in general
so now you see why the concept of the spider-verse
in spider-man 3 is so important for helping them
set up the next 10 years of spider-man stories in
general not just tom holland spider-man stories
but all spider-man related movies because
you have the sony movies the venomverse
morbius all the stuff they're trying to do with
the spider-man characters that they control but
that aren't in the mcu at this point and you have
other characters like miles morales that marvel
has already introduced in spider-man homecoming
but they haven't really activated like he's still
kind of riding the bench so to speak from a story
perspective they haven't really turned him into
a big big character yet when i also say they have
some financial reasons for wanting to roll so hard
on spider-verse you have to think about it this
way spider-man far from home made over a billion
dollars at the box office and they had avengers
end game is the lead-in which gave them a little
bit of a bump sony is thirsty to make another
billion plus dollars on spider-man 3 not less
money like what would get your casual spider-man
fan not a super fan but just a casual fan
way more excited to rush out and buy 4 tickets for
his entire family to see that movie bringing back
tobey maguire andrew garfield and some of those
other characters and even though the memes are
going to be off the charts and we'll be making all
kinds of jokes about tom holland being a backup
character in his own franchise when really this
should be all about tom holland's mcu spider-man
despite the rogue's gallery of characters that
they're piling into spider-man 3 most of those
characters will probably just have very very
brief cameo scenes there was even a rumor recently
that they were trying to get leonardo dicaprio to
cameo in the movie because at one time before they
made the tobey maguire spider-man movies james
cameron was going to make a spider-man trilogy
and he was going to be james cameron spider-man
but this is way back in the 90s it's just the
concept of them trying to get as crazy with the
live-action version of this as they did with the
animated version the animated spider-verse movie
was great so theoretically if they can pull it off
the live-action version of that would be even
cooler and from a practical plot perspective the
next 10 years of spider-man so to speak kevin
feige has already confirmed that sony plans to
cross over tom holland with tom hardy's venom
and it would be a sony movie not an mcu movie
it's much easier for sony to do all their
universe building in the venomverse with movies
like morbius the other venom sequels maximum
carnage if they just say it's all happening in
an alternate universe and use the spider-verse
twist live-action spider-verse in spider-man 3
is also the easiest way to help set up the concept
of miles morales spider-man down the road so that
they can do their own trilogy of movies with him
who knows what they would call it as long as they
don't use home in the title i'll be fine but like
i said they still want to keep tom holland around
for as long as possible because he's kind of
like the new robert downey jr iron man character
spider-man as a character is probably one of the
most important characters to marvel's identity
in the history of marvel comics they even put
his face on every single comic that they shipped
for a good long while he is also one of the few
characters who remembers everything that happened
before avengers infinity war he was there for that
and he'll be there for all the stuff that happens
after avengers end game so he's sort of the bridge
between the marvel phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 stuff
and all the stuff that's coming in the future
with marvel phase 4 and eventually x-men
fantastic four stuff so he brings this point
of view perspective that's invaluable to the
storytelling going forward so solid chance that
he cameos in the next fantastic four movie with
john watts because they've been working together
for so long then after that he just starts coming
back for the big big crossovers like avengers 5
and then potentially coming back to help mentor
a young version of mcu miles morales once
they eventually introduced that character
and i think one of the few changes that they'll
probably wind up making is they'll find a way to
introduce miles morales without killing off tom
holland's main mcu spider-man is it going to kill
spider-man off as part of the ultimate spider-man
origin story it would probably be someone like
andrew garfield or tobey maguire spider-man
the older world weary versions of spider-man
but let me know in the comments though if they
start using spider-man more like iron man giving
him more avengers crossovers instead of solo
movies after spider-man 3 and spider-man 4
which movies do you want to see him in the
fantastic four affirmative and there's another
who was a big help to me against carnage and
venom there's another team of superheroes that
i've worked with before computer bring me one of
the x-men which one good question there should
be a new venom 2 trailer in a new morbius trailer
really soon morbius is still supposed to come out
in march there are a lot of spider-verse easter
eggs like the tobey maguire spider-man suit in
that so hopefully we'll start to see what's going
on with all these spider-verse easter eggs really
soon there is supposed to be some special marvel
trailer event on new year's in china so hopefully
some of that footage will make it online whatever
they wind up releasing i'll do videos for so as
long as you have alerts enabled for my channel
you should see all those videos when i post them
i'll be doing Wandavision weekly episodes
really soon too that'll start in a couple
weeks while you wait for everything click
here for that new marvel fantastic four
teaser the kevin feige released recently and click
here for that brand new Wandavision trailer and
big marvel x-men easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe happy new year!